okay four people joining this livestream
this is a late-breaking function an hour
on that framework for version 12
languages a thing for taking a network
so what is the relationship between this
and information information is what we
would apply to a classifier function
right right
so this is actually more analogous to
classify measurements and predictor
measurements okay so if I for example if
it just so I understand what what
happens here if I would say classify
country flag or what the heck is that
just a message because there's been a
unexpected cherry arrow bars have been
put depreciated so it's going to be
removed already ever no problem okay so
then if I say information of this
okay nice
okay that's good that's cool actually
why does that mouse-over have a have a
thing that looks like a dead could
because normally there's some hyper
parameters like it it will list the two
options to the method let's let's say
yeah but in that case I guess there's no
option so I get yeah okay so the next
the other thing you say as analogous is
what um this isn't a no it's a
classified measurements and predictive
measurements are analogous which yeah
they don't never just they are not
they're the same so here you give it
this set give the classify your eyes
they said and then measures okay well if
that needed a test that why didn't it
have a carrot in that case that's a good
point I don't know I mean the
documentation is clear it's automatic
right is should be carotene unless that
dot dot dot messed it up somehow that
would be a thing to go chase maybe soon
we could chase that okay so let's
understand what this thing is
you know I really wish you would do this
of combining these things in one line we
really don't do that so can we please
don't do that here
well actually I guess this is no I guess
it's okay actually that's good but why
don't you just put the ball hmm I guess
could be separated into like net a call
that I call and then net measurements
because I didn't set up a set up um um
the set up and the first thing that we
show in a situation where you have a bit
of preamble set up do we do a text line
so this measure the accuracy part that
refers to after you've done the setup so
how do you say setup okay look here's
what I would do I would say set up a
neuron that and training data okay tazed
800k obtained okay well it's
because you've got this you know okay
now you say measure the accuracy of the
thing on the test data measure the
accuracy of the network okay so let me
understand then what okay so we're going
back
um I call lying on our live stream says
this is really useful functionality
that's good um will it be possible to
allow our own accuracy functions EG mean
I owe you
well in fact I owe you is one of the UM
Jamie didn't get a chance to add this
yet but it is implemented which stands
for intersection of the Union if
anyone's what it is their IO uses the
radial part of its great loss layer
section
oh just down a bit Steve
okay
okay well so so what's the weather I
really don't think we should say capital
n that's really minor
a little slant yeah it seems a bit
weight to me but what was the reason for
that well the reason is that that that n
is actually any number so if you type
top five accuracy it's the top five
accuracy
oh you could tally you can't do that you
cannot do that okay there's already a
design for that in classical
measurements its accuracy like yeah
exactly open that exactly
yeah so so this actually just do
accuracy error and yeah the problem with
that is when we set up the a complex
measurement spec where there are
multiple other options we use an
association so we say measurement goes
to the string measurement you want and
then we have the other options and that
Association and I guess we could still
put a rule is gonna be a bit weird for
to dessert is really sorry it means
you're trapped it doesn't bind the wrong
way just does it is it bind left to
right and send it right to left
remember what is the case you're
describing you're saying yeah this isn't
right this isn't right this isn't right
when you say measurement there that's a
dummy measurement right no no that's it
that's that's the real strength
measurement because you're giving all
this extra information and then that
spec there is the kind of measurement
you want you could complain though that
spec there should be in a string because
most of these until now all of these
were string okay so the issue that
you're saying is measurement what you're
complaining about is the thing the case
where you say measurement arrow accuracy
arrow 10 okay yeah does that bind the
right you know that's the question full
form
okay it does that well use that that's
fun okay
and we've got to produce a key can we
can the T be called top five accuracy
what do you mean by a key what not when
so when this gets dumped into like all
the measurements you asked for and not
in this case but in Ned train when you
you can ask the very same things in
their train as part of the training
measurements option so when you ask for
those things it generates a key that you
need to identify that particular
measurement in all kinds of places
oh god I mean that's you can look at the
design is not straightforward
but and that keep equal top in it no
receipt or inaccuracy no I mean but
let's look at what it's what what's used
for here okay so so hold on
so first point is okay the first point
here what is training measurements now
so let me understand is an option for
net trade so that's very weird that we
have one thing called training
measurements and one thing called net
measurements okay what is the analog of
training measurements
there's nothing okay I don't think this
is the right name then because this is
an option right yeah
yeah so in fact somebody on our
livestream is already confused about net
measurements being an option it's not an
option it's a function
fused about how round measurements and
validation measurements combines with
net measurements
right so I I think this is the wrong
name I mean I don't think we can call
this
I think measurements has to be like
component measurements and all these
measurements things should not be
options right now I see your point
we've got a say in that name we've got
to communicate that it's something
you're requesting as part of the
training process so measurements hold on
these are so all of these things here
could be like tract measurement money
towards that's a that's a bug begorrah
but bogus or good it's sushma here oh
yes I'm here you put it could be with
the monito language
say what I mean we have we have a bunch
of money tour Cynthia I agree
so trading and you're using Ford I play
I am using no I seem to be using
production head branch okay from three
days ago no Joe men's money tour hold on
hold on hold on hold on you're talking
now about the training yeah training
measurements how we could call it okay
training progress function training
progress reporting so what what is the
relationship of training how does this
relate let me look for training
measurements
to make okay so when the training
measurements are made this is a Jamie
question I suppose when they're made
it's giving a bunch of keys that will be
fed to the training progress function is
that correct
yeah there will be um training progress
function will have access to those keys
net train has properties which will
include things related to these keys and
okay so then let me make a suggestion
okay we've got a thing called handler
functions keys which is an analogous
kind of thing right which says that
specifies that to which to apply handler
function so this is saying which keys
you should
um
which Keys you should expose to feed to
another function which is I think what
this is doing as well is that right yeah
but I think its primary function is not
to cook up some key values to feed other
functions its primary function is to
actually plot the things that you asked
for so when you when you do net train it
will see these things plotted that's the
way that most people will consume this
data
some people might also look at the
history of these results afterwards in
which case they get it for a key but
it's not the main delivery mode okay so
somebody suggested the monitor would I
think the monitor would is a good word
here um but let's try to understand when
we have other monitors
yeah those are expressions
yeah they typically rule delayed
well there's things like training
monitor keys
what about the word measure in active
form no no that's even worse it's an
option
you
well I mean other possible names which I
don't like very much training monitoring
and what about the sort of I guess a
name we sort of already rejected but
training metrics we rejected metrics I
think no because that would suggest the
opposite way around I mean that suggests
a thing that is being used to control in
my view
well it could be interpreted either way
the form which i think is seems to me to
be okay is training reporting
measurements I was about this on Samina
I mean training Madonna's reporting was
about saying that's the first I've heard
of your next generation at yen oh yes
that's true I the UM training uh let's
see um what do you see
trainee reporting measurements something
some no we don't want to use the word
measurements we don't want to use the
word measurements because we're
otherwise is going to get confused with
all these other things which are
actively making measurements yeah but
this is actually making no I know that
but but there are functions okay rather
than not I realize yeah I realize
okay so what we've got explain to me
what is training progress reporting
how come deltoid yeah that customizes do
you wanna turn a panel in a printed to
the command line
nothing progress bar so what was the
plane training progress by the way these
I think should be superseded by a more
generic option at some point maybe just
called progress reporting because I I
think it's going to be used in many
other places
eventually I agree it just says like
room your panel or just show me a bar or
from your print or show me nothing
physically yes I agree
okay training progress function why
doesn't this annoyingly have its way of
going to yeah was being fixed
I've have a way to go directly to the
documentation here okay
okay so what is this relative to the
training measurements
what does this do compare this with
training measurements and as the
training measurement says tell me about
accuracy and precision so you just say
training measurements error accuracy
precision as two strings and you get a
whole lot of stuff from that you get
plotting you get the histories of those
measures over time and so on what do you
get for training progress function well
that's more active thing that's here's a
callback to call with all kinds of
details that I can pick you know look at
how did that how does it display the
results of training measurements
relative to how it displays the results
of training progress function it does
not there's no nothing happens to the
output of the function returns doesn't
doesn't make a difference what your
function returns it's just there to look
at things print things wait wait wait
this function is supposed to take action
this training progress function can like
put up a dialog box and with a smiley
face in it and things like this is that
the idea
what is the relationship I don't
understand the relationship between the
training progress function and the
training measurements of a training
progress option and the training
measurements option so you might say
there two things is training progress
function and training progress reporting
okay training progress function is a
general-purpose callback you could use
it to save or store things or you know
it's up to you what you use that for
okay all right okay output doesn't
matter but training various reporting is
something different right but the
displays in some way okay so it displays
in some way and you can you can override
the default panel we that we provide so
you could display your own cool plots
and I've done it lots of times that you
see me down with that feature yeah okay
all right fine okay now when we do use
the properties and training measurements
in training progress function yes they
appear in a particular as some keys of a
key what's the key and there's several
keys because okay so they're round
measurements and validation measurements
and then those are those are that that
is telling you per round what these
measurements are is that the idea
correct invalidation measurements is the
same stuff but on the validation set
okay all right okay so that so that name
also is is dependent on what we call
this right yes Antonis I've got a here's
a particular way to size this which
would be to distinguish an abstract
thing like accuracy like the term
accuracy the notion of accuracy from an
accuracy measurement that's been made in
conjunction with the net and data so in
the scheme accuracy is the name of a
measure and the value 97 percent is a
measurement
okay which case this is training
measures rather than training regiments
that I think is unbelievably confusing
so look I mean given what we're seeing
training progress measurements seems not
completely crazy I'm reversing myself a
bit on on using measurements as a as an
option name but think if you see that
and you compare that with net
measurements I don't know what do you
guys think it's Tara Mia I agree with
that it's pretty clear that it's I mean
it goes with the family of training
progress function training progress
reporting okay what do you think I mean
then but then it's got to go along with
so then train
progress measurements would have round
measurements arrow and then the and then
these
these measurements here right
you lost me but
function will have round measurements
and how do you do with training
measurements to distinguish between the
training set and the validation set so
the whole point you're using training
progress function era and then in that
you're using round measurements arrow
something-or-other is that the idea yeah
wrong measurements is a key the training
purpose function gets access to the
super Association all these things of it
one of them is round measurements
another one is validation measurements
those are entire associations and to
themselves that have all the keys that
all the measurements you asked for and
their values
okay but then training measurements is
not needed you can just always use the
reverse function what how no because
because we got to know what to collect
it's expensive to collect some of these
so there's exactly the same issue as the
handling function key to handling
handler function keys yeah the reason I
don't think it's the right frame throat
is that the people the way people
consume this is they want to see the
stuff planted it's not so much about the
keys so are you saying that the just
setting what you're currently calling
what we're now calling trading in
progress measurements just setting
training progress measurements arrows
Scott type for example will cause it to
display Scott PI whatever that might be
independent of you saying anything else
is that correct or not as it as a
function of time
yes Oh Ames was for both both the
training and the validation
mm-hm in the exact same way we even
quickly do net trained analyst in that
shorthand that we've not documented how
do we see part of it we haven't
documented the Linette part because
that's basically only useful for testing
and for demos like this but the MS part
is worth documenting like Lynette is not
a model why don't you talk about this I
mean okay so we dressed market might be
loading something will optimize at the
very end of this whole process
I said that's error rate there yeah now
what your hands but now now if I do the
same thing and I say training
measurements the error you ain't see any
plotting we haven't hooked her the
plotting is the last thing to be hooked
okay
all right fine but by the way they also
the autocomplete was missing all the
training measurements right hand side
okay yeah yeah I gave it training
measurements and it seems to have done
is remove one of those images yeah I
won't do that in future but what will
happen is all these measurements will be
so like these will all be only known
equal footing so currently error rate is
kind of baked in an eleventh in eleven
three but in twelve aerators on the same
footing as accuracy is
prai's all of these things any of those
things you asked for okay
you will then get those things planted
live and you can I don't think we will
show one of the things I think we will
probably have a flipper so that you can
see you know it turns cool will classify
thing where you can flip back and forth
during the training process to see the
prep that you care about oh I think we
should change this to training progress
measurements sure okay I'm going to do
it okay
training regiments changes to training
progress measurements renamed okay all
right can can you guys follow through on
the renames for every place else that is
affected by this sure during the
progress those buzzwords measurements to
make while training is in progress I'm
just trying to get the word in like when
movies trying to get the name with me
it's just something I log I didn't know
they did that okay they um to make while
you're on that training is in progress
well no I can just say training we're
saying that trade nap
okay now let's go through these so you
we're getting rid of this horrifying top
inaccuracy right
so that becomes I mean you can do all of
these but but that becomes accuracy ro n
um
let's see what what world where to be
help what's that I think just stop in
Icarus you'll be fine
what does that mean fraction of
correctly classified examples but but
then what does it matter Amin what does
top end it that means you relax we're
what you call getting right so that the
correct answer is just in the top end
guesses by the classifier okay
well then for goodness sake let's say
that because somebody like me wouldn't
know what this meant otherwise so say
what you want to say here fraction of
examples in which the correct answer is
in the top man
the correct result in the top-end okay
can we can we use that then for um in
the error rate you know we can we just
need to do it for error rate as well we
could all right okay
now he's got him a beta scoff I'm sorry
we can use the same notation to add F
beta score which is the generalization
of the f1 score for different
waiting's between precision and recall
okay I don't know what that is but you
some it sounds like you do so that
sounds good to me
um okay all right so you'll add those
things okay so this is um and we've got
to go change training what was these
this was training measurements
previously and then we're going to go
back um so
okay that seems to only be on my page
and so you're saying training
measurements where would this be um
right at the bottom yeah managing data
and training it's a sucker dump zone we
won't have a separate page about this
this is an awful lot of things here
it's kind of high on guide page well
maybe I mean we should break up this
page a bit anyway but at very least um
yeah you know we should have a guide
page and then we can also put things
like that or make it a 12 you can put
things like how do i numerate the GPUs
you know get information about the GPUs
cruder could go in there through the
link okay okay so now we've got
well where are we putting these
functions like net measurements and so
on
yeah that's a good question I mean they
need a cross-linked to classify on
predictor I know that but where would
net measurements are net information
that's net
and Tatian so here what is this net
train results object okay but so here
shouldn't this be shouldn't net
measurements go in here I mean it goes
along with net information for further
now yeah it does go there okay so it
goes down at the bottom of net
operations yep
oops okay and the description is
what is the description do we use etc'
that kind of thing you measure accuracy
etc on the net well measure it relative
to what not measure measure the
performance of a net performance of a
net on a particular training on a
particular data scientist on say on
tested that's an approach best practices
yeah we don't want people measuring the
nets on the training data right
measuring measure the performance of a
net on test data
you
okay why this isn't showing up with a
correct 12-plus thing here there okay
all right
so now net measurements which we still
have to review a little bit needs to
point to
that has to point to training okay let's
let's look at what this points to
training progress measurements is that
is that the right thing for it to point
to there I think so yeah that's very
time it's it's closest relation okay
what about the donation net information
seems relevant to this
that's the static version Plessy for
information seems to be why there isn't
a classifier information item sorry
classifier measurements it's still there
we haven't depreciated it for deprecated
that seemed relevant as information
snorunt predict the measurements also
the identic information is not relevant
honestly okay
you
okay
okay so then in net train we are going
to point to I mean a net model
presumably should have
I mean net measurements I wasn't net
model relevant to this as well because
this is the performance
so the net evaluated on certain data so
isn't net model in the same way isn't it
chained on whatever no yes I mean I
would have thought this is relevant you
know net model net chain net graph are
all relevant to this but this will could
product in any net function in the
beginning I don't think what do you mean
in any net function I mean
yeah sorry what we don't do that well
now we did we could quit Nietzsche in
that graph because they are very common
pins from Nets you could put that in all
net associated functions but we don't
generally so why not in this case the
issue is you're applying the net
measurements to an existing it's not
only training you can do this you know
if I've got a net model look I think we
should at least put in that model in
there okay yeah I mean because it's
something that you can apply to an
existing that model I mean I I could
presumably say if there's actually round
on my machine nap model of the loan that
training set
you know what its accuracy is so in fact
can I see that could you just run that
so I understand what's going on can I
can't run it is that correct I don't
have this
um I don't think you have this we can do
this I can try as well I'm sure let me
know when you're set up you set up yet
or not give me a sec okay all right okay
ready all right go for it let's see
there's a net and then we say net
divisions net on em list that's not
documented but it just works by virtue
of shade occurred okay so let me just
see okay so that also raises the
question why they didn't give a carrot
yeah here we go okay so what is and
let's try recall that for example but I
think the term computing measurement is
very odd okay what should we say well
it's either making a measurement measure
measuring the net performance or
collecting collecting measure how about
collecting measurements in measurement
data
because not everything is performance
related right uh is it gonna have a dot
dot dot at the end of that I don't
really know what I forget what the
format is there okay so first of all in
the examples of net measurements I
really think you should give this like
first their book it's a very simple use
you know I have to set up this whole
elaborate training you know training set
up maybe you did give this first but I
think you should just say net
measurements of net model Lynette blah
blah blah comma you know that thing
comma yeah what yeah what we can do is
we can in fact let's do that and then
put a divider and then we can do the
setup for more complicated example and
then yeah right exactly
okay um that's Isis we don't wanna do
want to talk about this suppose we can
it's kind of la I mean just put resource
data of that it's it that nobody is
going to be upset by saying resource
data of that and then it's also clear
that you're talking about the test
version of feminist because there's
tests and training oh okay well fine to
run that down run that run that from
what you have there
it's bit slower because resource stages
a bit slower
oh you have to I was there differently
configured okay beautiful okay all right
and shovin okay okay so we've got some
knitting to do here we've got to look at
the natural net measurements thing so in
it we've got here
got training measurements becomes
training progress measurements
you
correct does anything else need that not
to my knowledge
okay I'll go through and look at various
places and make sure okay
okay so this then after net train needs
presumably at the end of this actually
net train okay so at the end of that we
should mention net net measurements
right
yeah I suppose we should because it is
now yes it is now the kind of net
branded way to measures and we not
mention that information here or should
we not bother with that we could yeah
because it'll require weights and then
you can see how big the way it's long
over yeah okay
why doesn't that information sorry why
doesn't that information exist why isn't
it just information are we deleting one
of the well I don't know we're doing it
all for 12 but um I mean I'm competent
to to delete that but but does does
information work in the same way that
net information works I'm probably not
as known that hasn't come up on my radar
but I'm sure bug will be filed or we'll
find the bug now but I don't know I mean
at en you're the Guru of the soul
information function applied to these no
no I mean I can have tally and Nick talk
to each other but probably not so much
in 12 okay fine yeah okay so so Sushma
can you then note that this needs to be
yes yes okay let's go back here so now
we know by the way with a new question
mark syntax
oh sorry to interrupt but you are you
segwaying is something totally
irrelevant telly no I'm just asking
about information so with question mark
the new question mark um if you had a
chain like could you say question mark
of knit would it see that as a static
symbol and go I don't know what net is
what I mean if you said net equals
something and then later on did a
question mark of net but how is
information supposed to work on on
expressions that already exist rather
than symbols question mark isn't
information anymore I think
question mark is a slightly modified
version of information which doesn't
evaluate for example
so canids if you if you had a you say XX
x equals 67 or something and I say
question mark xxx if what you're asking
is there it is
I said that was an it it's not gonna
what would it do it wouldn't say it
would give me information about the net
would it no idea tally that's right
so what tally is saying is if you say
question mark that that's actually not a
bad idea right that if the value of xxx
is a net
that's what you're saying if the value
of xxx is a net for example if I say xx
x equals net model you know amnesty for
example Y doesn't mean to complain it no
I'm not confused that's why I can't
autocomplete um okay fine and then I say
question mark xxx
that's kind of not very useful if it
could be quite useful because it could
just delegate the information to the
value of xxx and trade it you know I
don't think that's not useful I think
that's useful I think um the question of
whether it then recursively goes and
gives you the information on this is an
interesting idea that hasn't come up
before
okay I I'm not going to I think it's I
as the keeper of the whole information
story so why don't we what wouldn't that
work because it's net information so
this is bad that should work that should
really really really work
I'm sure I can hook that up easily it
just hasn't come up on my radar yeah
well okay hook it up and then we can
expect to deprecate that information
sure
and by the way this presumably should
not error not produce a carrot there
yeah I don't know why that does that but
I'm curious by the way what how how do
we document what the properties are for
something like a net if there's no
symbol called net information in that
graph net Shana yes that's right what we
decided recently as information will
delegate its documentation for sub cases
to the functions whose you know that are
being information if I'd so to speak so
for example for a graph
it'll be graph that says what
information does on graph so to speak is
there is there a spiritual section from
a tours of properties in relations
good question it's part of the details
but the question of how we show that
yeah where we do it's a really good
question where do we show it in the
examples
humph well I think it depends how
important it is I mean it could go hmm
just take it take a quick look at that
information I mean my concern
specifically what that information is
that because it was its own little
domain there's all kinds of cool stuff
there that much he as long as and I
could work on any net so like would be
replicated one of this in every layer
that doesn't seem right to me
where you're talking about how the
documentation works look yeah okay so
listen listen the four 12.1 the idea is
to have just like we have format pages
okay
we're also going to have information
pages that are the descriptions of this
stuff for you know information about
different categories of things
so that's where we can share that
information share the description of the
the parameter the properties for that
information thing merci
okay so Sushma that that's some
unscrambling for you to do there what
has to happen with this okay um all
right so let's come back here alright
I'm sorry let's go back we were net
measurements which we still haven't
discussed fully and net measurements
certainly points to nap progress
measurements
training progress measurements that's
fine all right we got some questions on
the live stream here okay hold on
third argument of net train no that was
can
fused okay how can he
asking how can I add my own accuracy
functions in general
the answer to that so in other words
their own
measurements what what
pure function here instead of a name
here in
measurements whatever you could measure
here you could just evaluate the
function to compute that but the
question is if you want it in training
progress measurements how do you put it
in there
so which is the question how to specify
user-defined metrics that's correct so
we support that as long as that
measurement can be calculated in the
computational graph so if you can define
it using graph operations by using our
layers so how where do where do you put
that in well in the net and then that's
what that net ports and taxis for which
oh here oh yeah that is my guys so I see
okay so you're gonna give examples that
show that okay fine so you actually
compute it the network itself computed
it's basically the point you're making
no yes and that is obviously more
limited it's not I mean there's still
and what you can do with that but it's
it's more limited than what you can do
by providing some arbitrary function we
do want to eventually support an
arbitrary function as well okay fine
okay question here
[Music]
is learning rate a top-level option to
nach train and now it is okay all right
um
if you're talking about performance of a
net is there a measurement for speed of
execution in that measurements that is
an interesting question that is a cool
one that actually occurred to me and
Jamie recently realized we should
probably support that kind of thing kind
of metadata track measurements that's a
lot of this one I don't know others I
think things like what the length of V I
don't know what the analog of the you
know the length of the neuronal path so
to speak from input to output
if that means something so that there
would be a static measurement I think we
have that it's called flow depth or
something um well it's not listed here
no no no that's it's a static thing so
it doesn't depend on the data that's
something like native information okay
hold on things which are in net
information should also presumably be
supported in that measurements correct
because
it seemed useful to be able to make a
measurement that just happens to be a
constant mhmmm it could be I mean it
seems silly to have to have two
functions that you have to call if
you're just generating a list of things
for the network like you might want to
say the error rate you might want to
make a table of error rate versus layers
for example for a bunch of CPUs course
well then I think the way that we should
support that is just to have a notice
that says all options and net
information are also supported and
monster-like
belabor it with another table that's
fine
um okay but now let's come back to okay
so there's the possibility of actual
speed measurements which I think would
be definitely be useful people would
really care about that of course
ultimately what they really want to know
is if you were to deploy this thing on
some other platform how it would it you
know with some random and some random
TPU or some other weird thing like that
what would happen that's gonna be hard
there's something related in information
so if you do information of a classifier
probably there's no work with a built-in
classifier but if you train a classifier
like you do classify whatever 1 2 3 4
goes to 1 1 and 2 2 let's say or can
take an example from documentation as
you want well why don't I just do random
integer 10 comma 10 arrow
this is gonna be brilliantly trained
yeah random thing anyway okay and if you
do information on that actually it kept
inside an example and it did some
benchmarking single evaluation so it did
on your computer so if you explore this
to another you know ok training camp
where it's a single evaluation time
exactly this if you give one example to
the classifier to the classifier it will
take about three milliseconds to run on
your computer
and if you give a batch of example it
will typically do 74 examples per minute
on your computer
yeah it's not only training computer on
the one that took classifier is it's
being run right now yeah right yeah okay
so what's the our log of that so that's
really nice
I don't quite understand why information
or net information then wouldn't be the
place to put this yes because it's not
it's independent of the test set yep
actually like I agree it could be a
different number of next texts you know
viable ends examples to take much longer
like a regular network would run much
longer longer you know that's true good
but but look this is clearly a really
nice thing to be able to have net
information which is I mean which a net
information I will be great if you could
look at a grandfathering in what's in
that information into information even
for 12 oh just because we want to have a
consistent story for information people
won't fill so you can leave the
documentation for that information okay
I assume there's some internal API that
I just look into yes supposedly seen it
with my own eyes but actually I did
speak metric for closer measurements as
well I believe right that could be net
measurement as well related properties
yes evolution time but revolution time
yeah um I I do want to do that stuff I
think that the evaluation time is a slam
dunk net measurement I mean yeah there
would be it's basically time for example
I think is the right unit because the
batch size is completely could be
selected at random what happens
I just say classify measurements hope
you know without giving a parameter here
we'll do the Casio measurements object
okay so why we've shown that we should
show that in the documentation early on
because this is I mean if I just say
okay so if I just do this oh no that's
not useful oh I see it doesn't it
doesn't give a nice yeah no no it's a
hold on hold on net medical report yeah
I think it should do something like this
I think this should display like this
yeah actually it exists a report but I
didn't hook it so it looked you know in
the so if you do report of that do
report oh sorry
yeah percent and then key yeah whatever
yeah report and this this is something
probably that should go directly into
the yes except I limit layout why is
that so I mean for goodness sake don't
make that so big in this case why don't
you just asked design to give you a spec
they've done this a zillion times before
for these things there's a spec for how
to get this to not look stupid when
there's that little data in it okay but
so what is this actually returning so I
mean classifier measurements I hope we
don't have a net measurements what is
net measurements of two arguments return
we don't support that we could and
support and we could return on net
measurements objects not that not
another object well I don't know what
what does information do information I
believe is just what is the input form
of percent 34
oh my gosh Wow
okay just said stuff you could not reuse
it after to query priorities so Cory why
didn't care about what it was
okay well it's arguably at some point
yes and arguably there should be sort of
an information object or something that
is the display because yeah because that
display thing you should be able to
query the keys of that like if you've
got that information object for an
accuracy surely that should work yes I
agree completely so I think it should be
an information object and that's how
that should be packaged sushma that's
for you again mm-hmm and I'm trying to
check all did you do that but let me
check that but it doesn't seem to be the
case I mean in okay five seven percent
thirty four sub might just be for my
stuff oh yeah because yeah I don't think
it's right there okay so if I say
information of let's say Italy or
something then I should be able to get
the entity information thing and now if
I say that
you
yeah so that works so there's a goof up
somehow in in yours
@n yeah
what's that that's what the code font
and like full data strong it's an error
it's coming tomorrow um okay so okay so
hold on so let's let's zoom out for a
second on this stuff okay so Etienne
there's this problem that you should be
using information data Tali
there's the let's try to get rid of net
information if we can actually get rid
of it that would be great
and just folded into information but at
least we should make sure information
has that functionality okay and it
should return an information data object
that um has the right properties okay
okay sure back to by the way this
information that object seems like a
good general purpose carrier for things
like the measurements right once you've
got the measurements if you do the two
odd form of measurements yeah why not
but it seems like it's the same notion
of a bunch of keys and it displays
nicely yes yeah I agree
one thing all the Kettleman reports
should look like this report I mean when
you just do casey ferrand measurements
okay to argument so you have the
classified measurements object should it
look like which type of blog should it
look like one of these I mean sorry as
opposed to what by the way
sizes here your font size is simply too
large so what we are doing with
classified information is we are just
you know getting whatever it can have
done so far all right fine fine okay so
this is a 12 oh heck yeah yeah and I
think okay all right fine I mean if he
has the chance to go down and font size
but don't do it if it's gonna break
something
okay no no I can do that yeah so as
opposed to something test for
measurement and then open bracket and
there is a panel inside you know with
the plus like net chain there's like
mr. Wain yeah I understand isn't there a
way with information of having a plus I
thought information had a way to expand
it should have okay so for certain kinds
of things when you get information there
will be above the fold stuff and below
the fold stuff so so look at here needs
to be shown the API for the information
thing for measurements asking actually
it's a bit different okay but I think
it's the same it should be the same
appearance
I mean well whether yeah I understand
that measurements we'll have something
where you need to have be able to go
below the fold as well the thing is for
measurements it's okay for information
the main use case is you just so the
receiver report yes and and you or if
you want a specific property then you
use information directly forecasts for
measurement its specific that when you
do custom measurement there's a lot of
competition to happen that doesn't have
to be repeated to ask for several
properties so it's a typical workflow to
first do class for measurements with two
argument and then you have this thing
that you can ask disguise accuracy let's
ask a role as f1 score and it's a bit
interactive what you can ask to it so we
need to make sure like when I see a
report like that I don't think I can
compute stuff from it
well when you see a sort of blob you
know with the classifier measurements
head then it's a bit more clear that you
can ask stuff to it
if there's a plus in it it will also be
clear that you can go and ask more stuff
hi I get what you're saying I get what
you're saying I I still think we should
standardize on this information think
people will learn that you can you know
do sub values of the information it's
only one thing to know and it's very
general because it's across all
information blobs everywhere
make sense yeah confirm Asian but for
for measurements but I'm saying its if
the blob looks like an information blob
people will assume that you can do sub
values on it because tell values on an
information blob okay
okay let's take a few more things from
the livestream here and then I want to
come back to going through the details
from that measurements
um
yeah so
be rolled into a single measure model
model measurements or something other
than having all these classifier
measurements and predictive measurements
and that measurements yes yes we do want
to do that okay random question here
about being able to do net train on an
AMD GPU I'd like to know the answer to
that
yeah that's um that's something that's
up to Andy they've I mean they do have a
I said look suggesting is the big expert
honest I'm not I haven't followed the
details closely but I need you know the
rough story which is that you know
there's been this Intel has Peter and
Andy has open Co and that's historically
being this kind of schism or frameworks
and broken seals completely died like
for the point of view of deep learning
it's not it's not kind of inaction in
any of the major frameworks which one
it's not a contender but Andy has been
switching to I think it's called rockin
which is a kind of a kind of new sort of
update that does come back in the
running with with deep learning and I
think that is being ported to the
various frameworks I don't think it's
landed if it had landed will it be
differently using it but it's not
something that's in our control to to do
it's a kind of it's a move by the
principles themselves to kind of add
that support for the major frameworks as
soon as the framework support them we
will support nd cards right okay
oh there's interest
suggestion perhaps a GPU profiling
through a network to our benchmark suite
that was an interesting idea
gosh where does that go we I mean that
the benchmark thing needs to be updated
anyway
if nothing else that is a good student
project to try and find some find some
appropriate things do there Sushma cut
perhaps you could remind me and I'll add
it to that list but in addition if you
know who is doing the update to the
benchmark stuff that will be somewhere
in our notes area it's good that I'm
predictable repeatable okay okay nice
box would be great for net train results
object
what does net train result object to now
I think it looks okay can always good
things look better but if you go to the
doctor page you'll see what it looks
like
and it's rather nice actually I mean we
could certainly make that into more
information the interface because it is
very similar since properties property
lookups
we should do that I think but why is
this
try
what what is this doing how why does net
train I mean that train normally just
returns a network
what is this this is some kind of hacker
Soros with with that third argument all
no I mean that's documented and you
proved that um yeah okay well that's
right there was an 11-3 thing but can I
say something I do think this should be
the default that net rain returns rather
than the treinta net because then at
that point you've thrown away so much
useful information I think it's worse
than asking people to dig off the trend
net and that that's bridge was already
big cost for the function called net
train we can have another function
anyway all right fine well I'm not
thrilled with this I would like to
revisit this when we've cleaned up all
the information stuff revisit how net
train results object books okay
nice to see a temporal breakdown of
where the bottlenecks are in execution
closet across various batch sizes I mean
that's a fun one so that would be like
benchmark like a kind of profile in the
net so like the saying this lays
responsible for most of them those jokes
are starting to list in a mixed state so
differently we have the ability to to
track that information back from MX Ned
to North America it's quite a lot of
work to do we haven't had a chance to do
that for this version it might be
something we do for next version and
that would show up where measurements
would be the obvious place to do it
because that's where you get later all
right our final act here is to actually
go through net measurements right in US
unless somebody else has something else
that the pile let's look at net
measurements here okay why don't we say
computes the requested measurements
because that's got to do some work
you
you
okay a measurement
have any
you
load it up port than that
we should delete that third usage sorry
that was copied across from trainee yeah
training no wait the one with the wait
so for training progress you do want to
see like oh the weights max you know the
magnitude of the weights is changing
with net measurements it doesn't change
so obviously that's a stupid thing to
ask for you can't ask for it but it's
not useful to point out this one here
the weights yes the weights
other the same as those for the
additional settings are the same as
those for training progress measurements
prefer I hate using these things where
you were oops
so in it so
thing is that net measurements
all
properties from net information
can also be used as built-in
measurements
is that correct yes
hypothetically if we did remove in its
information of this version of what
would that sentence read from
information of net and so Sushma you'll
need to search for that information if
something if we succeed in doing that
okay so nets that can
cross-entropy layers
I was gonna say this thing so we're in
it but but what
nets that don't have either of those
things what can you do with this
hmm you can do the net port so I mean
the way it breaks down is that for nets
that contain crossings realize there's
so many lost players there's a kind of
what makes a net into it it's how you
train a classifier classification it
that what distinguishes a net that is
going to be used to classification but a
net can be used for both classification
and for prediction mean squared loss the
mean absolute loss are used for
prediction as well
okay
we'll need to remove the top and stuff
and yes yeah I you guys need to do that
hum so that's
that way I suggest a syntax that when
you do net port you can actually put a
rule and that port rule and then you put
a pure function that we basically apply
to all the result is already not clash
okay then that would more or less solve
the problem of being able to get an
arbitrary function evaluating stuff on
the network that correct yeah which
would be part of a solution but net
measurements itself doesn't there's no
place you call a niche in sight
measurements so it's related all right
let's have a quick arrest of these area
under ROC curve this is already stuff
into so measurements though actually
everything here has been gone through
there's a few new thing Falls omission
right is new which will begin to show
measurements as well we have to put it
all the other ones are that you're
reading right now are there okay oh yeah
infraction yeah this stuff on you
fraction brains and explain our new
intersection of a union on you and s
squared is new
okay looks reasonable to me yeah go
ahead
is that long a name for our squared
correlation I call it's coefficient of
determination I mean is it the R squared
lower case R squared that's the that's
the thing used by all bad statistics
things confusing which tell you no no no
no I'm talking about the R squared which
is when people say I've got an R squared
of 0.9 a correlation between this and
that with an Oscar at 0.9
you know no okay the correlation
coefficient yeah I think not the
correlation coefficient the coefficient
of determination
I'm perhaps confused but there's a thing
called r-squared that you compute
yes it's also known as coefficient of
determination
but I mean it
I'm trying to actually they say R square
is oh when okay okay I think in some
case R squared is simply the square of
the sample correlation coefficient yes
oh but I mean it's not what this is or
it's something different this is
something different okay then we go to
say what it is because I at least I'm
confused
what is this now I think you the same
things give an average generalization
because in Wikipedia I can see when I
intercept you think you need then R
square is the square of the correlation
coefficient so maybe in the linear case
it's what you call the square of
cohesion cohesion but okay for non
linear prediction I read something
different than normal
I mean Wikipedia also says at the top of
the page for coefficient of
determination not to be confused with
coefficient of correlation which is why
don't we ask somebody in the statistics
team so we actually get this right no
this is
okay to get somebody we're running out
of time here but but I wonder if maybe
go Xie okay let me see if we can get um
you
ah okay is there anything else we have
to deal with here
other than that limit the standard
deviation is not the root-mean-square if
it's called standard deviation why isn't
it saying standard deviation of
something it's not the root mean square
of the residuals it's either the
standard deviation of the residuals I'm
confused here no no here you're not
removing the mean so
but you're saying the residuals have
already subtracted else do we say that
in our touch for measurement I'm just
fairly certain that's where I got it
from but perhaps I made a mistake
well that blob would be predictor
measurements those second things yes
yeah oh it's in pretty tourneys this hmm
well that's what you said there uh yes
deviation baseline okay I don't know
what any of these things are so I'm
officially confused no sorry it is a
wooden square
a square once you've got the residuals
yes if you've yes that is what it is
because your model making residuals as a
Garson you're asking what is the
standard deviation of that Gaussian but
it has to have mean zero that's the
assumption own right because it's
residuals yeah yes I don't remove the
mean so it's fine now we could debate
about the name some deviation or not
because it's not as television of the
residual that's very important
no is the root mean square of the
residuals it seems like the wrong name
to me but because I remember yeah what
about reach mean square because you've
already got a mean square which is the
mean square of the residuals and so
literally just well you said if you said
residual mean square no I just called
mean square for that means cause there
is drawn so yeah we could call it would
mean square as well yeah it's a bit
technique or salivation people
understand I don't know I think we're
not gonna solve this problem right now
able to find the most obvious person
from the statistics team though there
are several others I think it will be
worthwhile for you guys to spend a few
minutes with the statistics folk and
just go over these that seem reasonable
okay
all right did we net everything here
correctly
pacifier measurements does it refer to
net measurements probably not not we
don't knit until you approve that name
okay so why should we so what we net
measurements probably wants to be pretty
early in that list I have some variation
doing here classifier information
doesn't even exist anymore it's just
information right it still exists we
haven't duplicated it yet yes we need to
make a decision how that's going to work
okay so then this should say okay so
somebody Gosha will join us okay so that
then we should say net measurements
somewhere here where should we say that
I would suggest after classify our
no measurements yes it should be after
pretty measurements I think that's
okay so that's classifier measurements
now we need to have
the dental measurements will refer to
classifier measurements and then this
will come after that
you
you
you
okay question from our livestream will
the revamp loss function option be ready
for 12 my sincere hope that it will be
because I think it's super important for
ergonomics of all kinds of things right
in fact I believe we have a meeting
tomorrow currently on the calendar for
3:00 Eastern about loss function that's
correct
might be nice to go exact
for the definition of the measures agree
or appointed aware they defined yeah
well I mean I think ultimately we should
have some kind of tech report that
describes all of these things in more
detail we just have to have time to make
it okay what are the missing do we have
to do here and I guess Koecher was gonna
join us so we hopefully can get some
input on this process I am already here
huh okay all right we are looking at
this net measurements function and it
has various kinds of statistics related
things here which we don't really
understand in particular it has an R
squared that is supposedly a coefficient
of determination and what is the
relationship between that and the
correlation coefficient which is the
usual Pearson ish r-squared that a
reasonable question
oh no I you know what yes it's I don't
know exactly the formulas but we we have
this also in the in the linear models
and dessert this is this is having
computed through their estimates they
don't recall that the proper formula on
top of my hand but so in linear model
fit where would it be so that some of
these measures yeah in this in the a I
see you sir just at R squared and R
squared at the the last table here
properties that measure the goodness of
feet okay
I think okay now I'm reading more I
think you say it is the square of the
corrosion coefficient only when the
model is a linear regression okay in
general for arbitrary model apparently
the formula it's 1 minus the ratio of
the sum of square of the residual and
sum of square of just the data that's
yes it's the basically the fraction of
variance that is explained
a model but one - that remain remainder
right yeah
variants of original / variants of the
data and one - that okay so what you're
basically notice on the net but yeah
didn't you say we should change this
description to be coefficient of
determination is that right I think that
would be the consistent thing if you say
means square of the residuals and so on
well okay can you um so go show your
linear model fit must also have things
like means square of the residual
somewhere but true or is that not true
mm-hm look here's it look studentized
residuals for example this is fairly
confusing but but let me just understand
net measurements is making the the
goodness of fit measured by net
measurements is the same kind of a thing
as a goodness of fit measured by the
linear model fit there should be some
analog of net measurements for linear
model what is it or is it in the linear
model func object itself it seems to me
in the way a model object itself I mean
the yellow feeds you can see well you've
got future that's right under your
cursor there and with that I mean you
can get the other things I guess right
so I'm just trying to understand in the
case of net measurements and ferocious
benefit this is not a static measurement
on a network this is a measurement with
respect to certain test data
okay whereas for linear model fit there
should presumably be a similar notion
you've got a fit and the question is how
good is that fit on particular test data
is that true
I think it's only on the training data
feed yeah I understand
did we lose go sure oh no I'm just I
mean I don't know what what what you
know what the net measurements are
actually doing so I know the linear
model feet you can you you you know you
can find that the residuals between your
model and your data so you know what you
expect and what you have and I just
don't know what what we have you know
here let me go through what I've been
saying again because I see what I know
it's not what I'm talking about so for
linear model fit you have certain data
yes and you are finding a fit to that
data you were then asking and the fit
you have found is a model and you can
then ask with respect to that data which
we could refer to as training data how
good is your fit mm-hmm okay now in the
case of net measurements there are what
what you traditionally do with neural
Nets is you use one training set and one
test set what it sounds like you're
doing yeah I mean foot for a neuron that
basically you're trying to perfectly fit
to the training set whereas for a linear
model you know that a linear model
cannot perfectly fit the the original
you know the data unless the data
happens to be you know linear in some
sense right so in the neural net the
conceit of the neuron that is with the
right training you can perfectly fit the
training data therefore there's no point
in doing a goodness of fit to the
training data it's only a point in doing
goodness of fit to a validation set or
you know a test set that is that a fair
characterization yes because and in fact
it's this and the the sort of the the
way to say it and the certain textbooks
would be let's have such large capacity
can't have such large capacity that you
kind of guaranteed to overfit if you
train for a significant amount of time
yes and in that situation it's not
interesting to see how well it does on
the on the tip on the training data like
so low capacity that
you don't worry about others it exactly
in the ducts I imagine at least I would
have a fit as well for example if you
have many many many features you would
offer it as well but I guess historical
interest explody mention and so I guess
that's why this problem of ar-15 was
less important and right but so there
isn't so a question for
um
I don't even know what it means to have
I mean there isn't an analog of a test
set for statistics right for a linear
model fits and things it's just I mean
in the community yes we don't have it in
our long in our language there is an
animal okay so walk me from the analyst
what's that
now what is the analog of net
measurements for the the standard I mean
by the way a good question which I don't
think we've really addressed is the
analog for our fitted models right
fitted model
is a thing
which Oh what does fitted mother
as fitted model work do you do you apply
fitted model to data to get something is
that how it works
first novel of that oh yeah that's right
so that the fitted model you give it the
data and it gives you the value mm-hmm
so it's like an interpolating function
why is it called fitted model not fitted
model function because in has more
properties like you can see then apply
defeated residuals to the model so it
stores small things yeah okay fine
you might feed it a picture of an
ostrich or something but in a simple map
model you might just give it a list of
three numbers which is analogous to what
you would give fitted model here there's
a list of three numbers this because
these linear models don't exactly deal
with pictures of ostriches and so on um
okay well all right so a question here
is with respect to these measurements on
normal mats to what extent should they
correspond to the measurements that you
can do on linear model right and the
answer seems to be there are
measurements for the linear model that
are direct analogs of the measurements
you do for the neural nets because the
quotes residuals what is a residual
would be the difference between what you
you know what you should have gotten
what you actually got it's a true
statement yeah I mean mean prediction
arrows is actually difficulty what we
just call arrow right oh no mean okay
that's what we call mean deviation in
that case oh no stand
okay that's actually the question we're
wondering how to call standardization
well they seem to call it or my IBM
confusing prediction arrows standard
arrows for the mean predictions but
that's women is that prediction over the
mean was that the me I mean I'm sorry
because I am I am not aware how you
measure you know what are your residuals
and you know what's your you know what's
what's the measure between you know your
for your residuals in the way right so
what what we have we basically we have
the differences so the residuals between
linear model fit between the data points
and what the model values gives us and
we have values and then we can you know
square them add them find the mean you
know and and and such and that will be
corresponding to you you know you have
some residuals I understand
here I don't know between what you know
what that I mean I just don't do the
same the same it between the exactly the
true value and the pretty good right so
so it's so that'll be the kind of the
same thing so you have your residuals
and then if you so desire the
differences and then if you if you use
the you know the if you square them or
you standardize them you know you have
kind of the same idea in that way right
but I don't I mean you can I mean that
the point is that when you look at the
you know the difference is you want to
square them so you kind of you errors
always are positive and they don't
cancel with you if you you know add them
right so hence the the mean square you
know so you you might want to find the
mean of your squared residuals for
example that you know in that in that
way so the mean of square residual where
where is it in this table I don't know
what it is I'm just talking on top of my
head
I know okay but you think there is a
it's somewhere here errors so so so some
mean predictions
he's probably single prediction arrows
no the equivalent of started Asian say
the question for the live stream that's
a reasonable question which is wouldn't
it be nice to have measurement functions
like this that can just be run on label
data independent of classifiers and yes
yes yes yes yes that should be another
function I think all of these will merge
into function I mean all of these will
merge in one function probably called
model measurements and then there should
be another function that is independent
of a model or just gives true data
predicted data and you compute stuff we
don't have a good name for that yet and
we need to figure out and you know put
that into right but so that could be
merged between the statistics functions
and these functions yes I mean doesn't
even even model measurements you should
be able to put a linear model fit or
whatever you want in it but there are
lots of models right do you aware of
that that linear models it is just one
of them sure they're more fitting
functions there's also time series model
fit and such and they have you know
little stay there kind of flavors and
you know their own things what you would
want you want the data and the model but
then you know how how do you fit you
know how do you proceed we know with
what modeling it's another question how
do you produce you know the ideal data
from the model might differ depending on
what's what you know in which area are
we talking about yes
but okay but it seems like there's a
collection of functions that have you
know quality of model measurements that
we need to align because right now we've
got two different versions of this for
the world of you know machine learning
versus the world of statistics and they
seem similar
but not quite the same and my guess is
that there were particular kinds of
things whatever it is the the cook
distances whatever those are which might
be specific to linear models and not
relevant to neural nets and something
else right but okay this is a project
we're not gonna get done obviously for
12'o but it seems like something where
you guys should separately talk about
this and see whether you can come up
with some merged idea here all right
anything else for this meeting okay so
some small cleanup to be done and Sushma
has a to-do list for the future and I
think we're in good shape here cool so
thank you all very much thanks to folks
on the livestream and thank you go chef
for that drop in on statistics um sure
and uh okay see you all soon